اربعه اشهر من الجدل حول توزيع مساعدات
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي على النازحين في
مارب بصمات العين لكافه افراد الاسره
المستفيده من الغذاء واشتراطات اخرى تمسك
بها البرنامج ورفضتها بقوه سلطات مارب
للحفاظ على امن وخصوصيه النازحين بسببها
توقفت عمليه صرف الغذاء وبدا شبح المجاعه
يلوح في مخيمات النزوح طبعا هو كان يقول
ان لديه اجراءات جديده ادخل ضمن خطه
البرنامج هذه الاجراءات
لم توافق عليها الجهه الامنيه والسلطه
المحليه داخل المحافظه نحن نعتبر من حق
السلطان المحليه الحفاظ على او من حق
الدوله الحفاظ على مواطنيها
فيها في هذه المرحله نحن يهمنا النازحين
وضع النازحين ويهمنا الا تحصل كارثه
انسانيه ومجاعه داخل المحافظه
فتح مراكز التوزيع لمباشره صرف المساعدات
المخزنه لاكثر من اربعه اشهر في دورته
السابعه من العام 2022
واعلن عبر منصاته التوصل لاتفاق مع السلطه
المحليه على استئناف الصرف دون التطرق لحل
المشكله من عدمه وفي عمليه الصرف هذه
استمر البرنامج بخفض كميات واصناف الغذاء
المقدمه للنازحين
عليها كان على ايش لي زوجه جريح ولزوجه
استشهد
حالتها ولا ان هي تفعل حاجه عندي الان
رجعوها كيس دقيق
وواحد بول يعني كيلو فول مدري كم هذا
والزيت هذا ما يستخدمه الناس
الجوع مع البرد يزيد من معاناه ثلاثه
ملايين من النازحين والمجتمع المضيف في
مارب فيما نشرت وحده النازحين صورا لمواد
غذائيه اتلفها برنامج الغذاء العالمي
اواخر يناير الماضي في مديريه رغوان دون
الرجوع للسلطات المعنيه في المحافظه بعد
اربعه اشهر من توقيفها كما تؤكد الوحده
التنفيذيه لاداره مخيمات النازحين يعود
برنامج الغذاء العالمي لصرف السله
الغذائيه للمواطنين ولكن بكميات اقل محمود
الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب